et ce soir le parti socialiste qualifie
cette visite je cite d'astuces politique
alors le chef de l'état at il voulu
reprendre la main après les dernières
controverses
il a également en tout cas et dans le
même temps accordé une interview à nos
confrères du figaro où il revient sur
les sujets qui ont fait l'actualité
valérie astruc éteindre les polémiques
objectif numéro 1 pour nicolas sarkozy
d'abord la polémique sur son fils jean
critiquée pour vouloir prendre la tête
de l'établissement de la défense plus
agréable depuis de la présidence de
l'épad est un poste non rémunéré
il ne s'agit donc pas d'une prébende
c'est une élection il ne s'agit donc pas
de népotisme
à travers cette polémique qui est visé
ce n'est pas mon fils c'est moi autre
polémique frédéric mitterrand là aussi
nicolas sarkozy apporte un soutien clair
à son ministre je ne laisserai donc
personne assimiler homosexualité et
pédophilie
c'est un retour au moyen âge qui fait
honte à ceux qui ont employé cet
argument
quant à la polémique sur le procès
clearstream nicolas sarkozy avait
qualifié les prévenus de coupables juge
indépendant
le mieux à faire est de laisser se
dérouler ce procès de faire confiance à
la justice et de s'abstenir de tout
commentaire
j'aurais été mieux inspiré de le faire
dès le début c'est toujours le prêt à
dire polémique
la cagnotte le projet de cagnotte
scolaire qui récompensent ray
l'assiduité des élèves
je veux dire ma grande réticence à
envisager une récompense financière pour
les élèves qui renonceraient à
l'absentéisme je ne peux accepter qu'on
puisse récompenser des élèves simplement
parce qu'ils vont à l'école